oh it's still okay
now it's saying that i'm live
so now let's see if the
chat
actually
will acknowledge that they see me
let's see if this actually works
uh
anyways
can see in here there we go
there we go okay
so a little bit before we get into this
um this is not a typical uh saturday
video for me normally these would be
pre-recorded things there'd be the live
chat and all that
but uh this time is actually a live uh
streamed thing so that means a couple of
things i will on occasion check the chat
but i'm not gonna be keeping up with it
the way i would on a live stream uh like
the bi-weekly tuesdays so i'm probably
not gonna catch much that isn't done as
a super chat just be aware of that just
so this whole thing doesn't take uh
forever i'm aiming for about an hour
we'll see how long it actually takes
and then in addition to that i should be
clear that this tier ranking that i'm
going off of is restricted to modern era
doctor who i considered some that
included classic the problem is there
are still too many gaps in my classic
uh doctor who viewing that there were
just too many of the things that i just
didn't know i didn't recognize them
so
um i'm i'm going with with this one
so
yeah
it does look like these are on here in a
more or less random order
so
yeah i can just kind of take them as
they come
so one of the things that's fun about
these tier rankings as opposed to doing
a hard number ranking is
i it gives me a little bit more wiggle
room to be like yeah these two are kind
of in the same area without having to
every single one
um
so
here we go we'll start with what we've
got here oh it's the
it's the vespa form
so i've got i mean i've got mixed
feelings on unicorn the wasp for a
number of reasons partly because of
of who wrote it but setting all that
aside i do enjoy that episode but
i've said and i will maintain that the
wasp is
super random and just
like
i think it's only there because it was
on the cover of the book that they
decided they were going to make as a
reference thing like there's no reason
for it to be a wasp it's not
particularly thematic it's not
particularly inventive
it's pretty bad
yeah that's that's kind of where i'm at
with uh
with the wasp the wasp is is pretty bad
so that brings us to oh what is his name
was it salaz it was something with an s
i don't remember his name specifically
but this is the
uh human villain from
uh dinosaurs on a spaceship which is an
underappreciated episode uh in my book
that is uh
that is a much better episode than
people give a credit for i think part of
the reason it's fun to crap on it for a
lot of people is because gymnal wrote it
and i'm not saying it's great solomon
thank you chat um so
i but i actually think he's pretty
interesting and i i like the way he kind
of challenges the doctor that he thinks
he's on top of things but the doctor
kind of gets it underneath him he's
appropriately ruthless he's not amazing
but i think he works pretty decently for
the story the only thing is like he's
just not super memorable he's not what
sticks in your head about the episode i
honestly tend to think about his um his
bickering robot
lackeys before i think about him
so
i'm gonna go
not bad but not good for him
um i was tempted to go pretty good but
like honestly i think he needed to be a
little bit more memorable than he is
uh to get up there
all right the flood oh
ah the flood
so
i one of my continuingly controversial
opinions on
modern era doctor who is that the waters
of mars is
a very overrated episode
it's
good
it's not bad it is good but
people talk about it like it's god tear
and it's just
not
[Music]
and the flood in particular while
a decently done execution of a variant
of zombies they are
ultimately
just zombies that infect you with water
instead of blood so i don't find them
especially
interesting
that having been said
they are utilized very well and if i get
over the fact that i don't think they're
nearly uh as original or as scary as a
lot of people give them credit for they
are used very effectively for the story
they in and they are quite memorable i
would not put them in a legendary
category but
they are pretty good um my
my reservations about that uh particular
episode being overrated aside they are
in fact uh pretty good um
oh god
oh dear
oh dear
so
um
forget what the actual
thing is called that's infecting her
this
this thing is just it's
the whole
idea behind
fear her is
so weird
and it would be one thing if it lent
into just being weird and surreal but
it's not it can't seem to decide on a
tone
and it's so
bizarre and like a lot of the plot feels
like it would have been more at home in
uh the sarah jane adventures yet at the
same time it's dealing with things like
uh familial abuse and i'm like this
but again i'm assessing the villains and
the monsters not the story
it's still not very effective like
what this thing wants how it behaves is
very ill-defined and i never feel good
picking on a child actor but like she
does not bring whatever was going to be
needed to make this thing work they
really should have overlaid
some other voices in there so it wasn't
just her whispering because boy does
that not sound like it's pretty awful
yeah
i i feel a little bad about that but
it's it's it's pretty awful
so
oh okay so this is the
um command dalek from
uh
journey's end and the stolen earth now
i'm a sucker for the commander daleks
for a couple of reasons uh one being i
love the super deep voice
that they that they do when they really
pitch nick briggs down a lot
and they really just have it be booming
and resonant and that like i like daleks
anyways i think they're already pretty
dang good villains but you add that
depth
to the
to the voice
and it's oh
that does something to me that honestly
like the it's arguable that the daleks
just as a thing should already be
considered legendary but like you give
me that booming voice
yep
yep i like it i like it a lot
devross okay
so
i gotta think carefully about this and i
also need to try and detach
um
my feelings about davorus in the classic
from this because i'm gonna try and
assess it just from uses in modern who
the reason i need to do that is one of
the things that really frustrates me
about davros
is that as good a character as he is
once he was introduced in genesis of the
daleks
basically every single dalek story
became a davara story going forward from
there and that
frustrates me
um
and i like davos but i feel like there's
plenty to do with the daleks without him
but again that's a
classic era issue
so
limiting it to modern
that gives us
his appearance in
stolen earth and
journey's end and um
the magician's apprentice and the witch
is familiar
so
i think his reintroduction
with uh with with ten with tenant
was pretty much flawless for what it was
gonna be in terms of reintroducing him
what his deal is
his anger the fact that he doesn't
really fully properly control the daleks
even though he likes to think he does
his nihilism that was all there really
well
the
the one where he faced off against
capaldi i'm a little bit more mixed on
because
i really kind of wished
that his whole
pleading to the doctor
had been sincere
i don't like that it turns out to be
a trick like it tracks it's something he
would do but first of all for all the
guys skills i have a hard time believing
he's that good an actor
like you're a scientist that doesn't
make you a good actor but even beyond
that like it would have been a great way
to to close out his timeline you could
still have him show up again at earlier
points in his timeline but it would have
been a great way to kind of close out
his timeline kind of in the way they did
with missy and i really wish they'd done
that so i think
because of that he's gonna go into
pretty good
he is good though
uh of the uh the dolls from
night terrors
the general thing i get from them is
that i i feel like people who are afraid
of them
are um just have an inherent fear of
dolls or mannequins and as someone who
doesn't they are generic
they function
there's nothing really
wrong
with them but like they're it's it's
just the generic threat
and they they fit the aesthetic for the
general vibe that the thing's going for
so there isn't anything really bad about
them and there really isn't anything
that great about them either
yeah like i'm not particularly spooked
by dolls or clowns so when i when i see
things that feel like they're leaning on
the inherent creepiness of these things
as opposed to giving me a reason to be
afraid of them
i like it doesn't work for me and i kind
of feel like that's the case here's part
of the reason i don't like the it movies
all that much either but like there's
nothing really wrong with them so not uh
not bad but not good for them
so okay
the monks
this is another one where i have to keep
in mind the
difference
between the monsters and the story they
were saddled with
because uh
the the two the
ex uh
extremis
yes it's extremists is really good
honestly that's one of my favorite of
capaldi's era i love that episode a lot
and even the first half of their
two-parter
is
decent and then even the start of lie of
the land is pretty good it just falls
apart about halfway through a little
little less than that
but them as villains i actually really
like i really like the way that they
operate and the fact that they insist on
very sincere
um
consent to basically take over a world i
like that
they
they have very effective propaganda
which includes altering people's minds
but it's also like giving the impression
that there are far more of them than
there appear to be i actually think that
the whole way that there's no reason
ever bring them back let me be clear
about that
but i think the whole way that they
operate is actually
really fascinating and really
interestingly thought out and they are
delightfully creepy to look at i
actually think they're pretty good
uh issues with the stories in which they
appear or at least the tail end of those
aside i think they are pretty solid
so that brings us to
the headless monks
it actually took me uh i i i was looking
at this tier i wasn't figure out where
to put people but i was looking at this
tier uh in advance and
i it took me a minute to even realize
what this was
but the headless monks
the headless monks are pointless
they're pointless
like
it's a neat visual
but
there's no like they're just there to to
have something creepier than just
soldiers
um
manning the uh the basic demons run for
um a good man goes to war but like they
don't
do anything and unlike say the dolls
from night terror they don't even like
add to the aesthetic they're actually
kind of
clashing with the aesthetic of
everything else going on
they're
they're
they're pretty bad
actually
they they
eat up a chunk of time that just they
don't deserve
i'm yeah
yeah i they they're not great and i like
that episode a lot
um and i'm not gonna put them in awful
because they don't drag it down for me
but they add nothing and it probably
would have worked a little bit better
without them there
um so that oh
okay
so
these are the sort of choking cloth rag
scarf things from
uh the ghost monument in series 11.
here's the thing about these
a lot of people
made a lot of fun
of these things pretty much right off
the bat
thought they were super stupid calling
them well i can see in the chat calling
you know rags the killer bed sheets
all this stuff and like
yes
but
here's why i like them
they don't make sense
to us
which is why people
make fun of them it's why they pick them
like why would anyone make a weapon that
operates this way well
someone with a completely different
thought process
with an alien thought process with an
alien approach to weaponry with an alien
societal history in terms of what
qualifies and is used as a weapon
i like them because they feel like they
were invented by a mind that works
completely different from a human mind
and i like that
a lot
it's something that i wish doctor who
would do more and actually something i
wish science fiction in general would do
more there seems to be this assumption
that once uh species becomes space
faring it's like all technology kind of
standardizes like they've all got ray
guns you know and they and they all have
you know a close equivalent to
teleportation and this and that like and
they never and you'll think about
different ways to do the technology but
not enough uh creators put thought into
yeah but what if they just did something
that to us
makes no sense because
we just would never think to do it that
way but they might and that's what i
feel like these things are that having
been said i don't love the whole thing
where like they scan the doctor's brain
and find out about the timeless child
which which doesn't even make sense
given what we find out later and that
she doesn't even have this stuff in her
head so
unfortunately as much as i actually love
these things conceptually the actual
writing and execution of them isn't
great uh which is uh kind of a standard
thing with a lot of chimney stuff so
they're gonna go in
uh not bad but not good
and i hope people understand why i won't
put them lower than that
so ah krasco
so
this is another one like here's the
thing
i've ended up not wanting to be because
i don't think he's had a good run but
i've ended up being a little bit of a
soft defender
of chibnall
not that i don't think he hasn't done a
lot of lousy stuff because
boy he
really really has but like some of the
stuff he gets him around like there's
really nothing particularly wrong with
that i think krasko is another example
because
again people found it very easy to mock
the idea of oh he's just a he's just a
space racist he's just a future racist
that's really why would somebody who has
that level of technology and that far in
the future still be caught up in these
petty things well why are we still
caught up in them
why are why are we in this century with
our level of technology and our under
level of understanding that people are
not fundamentally different based on the
color of their skin why do we still have
trouble with this is it really that
unbelievable
that somewhere in the far future there
are still people who hold these grudges
we like to think they would fade away
but if they haven't yet
why would they in the future
it'd be nice if they would like
absolutely don't get me wrong but like
treating it as an automatic assumption
no i i could buy that there's still some
people like this
and i think his plan while
again another thing that got picked on
him
for was the idea that
like well his plan is stupid all he was
going to do was stop one person when
there was an entire movement of civil
rights and others
yes that's true his plan is is stupid
but it's a plan that would make sense to
somebody with these biases
if you ever have had the
unfortunate uh circumstances of talking
to someone who is bigoted against a
group that you are not actually in so
they think it's safe for them to express
these thoughts around you you will find
some insanely conspiratorial things but
also some deeply overly simplified ideas
and again i feel like he embodies that
pretty well and i actually think the
performance is decent
so
i actually say he's pretty good
he's not amazing i don't want to
oversell him but i think
the more i think about it the more i'm
like yeah i
i think if you're gonna have a villain
with this motivation that's the way to
do it i think he works pretty well
but people are gonna
people are gonna snapshot
these and i'm just going to get torn
apart like they're they're going to take
stills and not have the context of me
explaining why i'm putting some of these
where and i'm just going to get torn
apart for this
hell i'm going to own it at this point
so the uh
the god figures and can you hear me so i
am already
on record
saying that can you hear me is
we haven't seen the centenary special at
time of recording but is the
best episode of jody whitaker in chimney
sarah i stand by that i think it is
actually an amazing episode i
love it and they are part of the reason
why i like them both fully logistically
in terms of it's been so long since
we've had someone show up that just is
rightfully
not phased by the doctor
just not impressed by buyer like you
know we know who you are we know what
you can do
so what
the time lords are not the end all be
all they're not the peak there are
things greater than you and they even
name drop some of them
so
um
i already like them for that but then
metaphorically the way they work and how
that feeds into the story in the episode
because
their whole thing is pitting
tooth it's going to worlds and pinning
two sides against each other until it's
all destroyed which is
metaphorically
how it how it's framing a lot of
depression which is a part of your brain
is basically attacking the other parts
that's how that can often work and
unless you can sort of get things to
settle well enough to start to you know
get get a support structure in place
work with a therapist get medication
whatever you need yeah you kind of tear
yourself apart from the inside out
that's how they operate
so i like them on the literal level of
how they work i really like them on the
metaphorical level of how they work i
know there's the criticism that it feels
like they're defeated too easily
it doesn't bother me but i also more
relevant to doing this tier list i don't
think it diminishes
their um their effectiveness as villains
i don't think it did
i think they're legendary
i'm gonna get so much crap
oh man uh okay this is oh okay so this
is interesting so this is from um
the lodger
see i can come up with these things if i
think for uh for a minute this is from
the larger this is just the ship
so it's not the silence but it is a
silent ship
and this was actually interesting this
is something that i do like when doctor
who and
um sci-fi in general
does which is how automated systems
in the absence of what they were
supposed to do just start operating in
ways that weren't necessarily what's
intended you see it in this you get it
in um
[Music]
uh the girl in the fireplace
where like the uh the wind the uh
clockwork droids were programmed to use
whatever was available to fix the ship
and were never told to not make use of
the organic life on the ship if they
could patch things up with it and so
this is operating on a similar level and
i
like that in general this idea of like
it's just gonna keep burning through
every single person on the planet if it
has to until it finds someone who
actually will function as a pilot
because that's what it's programmed to
do
and i just like that as a threat
um
it doesn't have a ton of personality you
know this kind of rudimentary ai
generally doesn't but i actually think
it's pretty dang effective for an
episode that i'm otherwise mixed on i
say it's pretty good
oh
the absorbal off
oh
boy
oh boy oh boy okay um
this is another case where i need to try
and divorce
the
the creature and the villain itself from
the story because
i know that over time love and monsters
has garnered some defenders
i'm sorry i still think it's real like i
i appreciate what it's trying to do
i think it's still really bad uh
really bad
so but setting that aside just dealing
with him
on his own
and with
uh all
apologies in respect to channel pup
um
who is lovely but
between the look
being one that's hard to take seriously
and the performance just not really
working at all and it would be fine if
he wasn't actually effectively killing
people i think there's a disconnect
between how goofy
he is and how dangerous he is in a way
that i don't find appealing
ultimately i think the episode he's in
is worse than him so i'm gonna put him
at pretty bad
uh if i were ranking the episodes the
episode
the episode would go on awful
um
oh
okay so the planet god
thing
uh from
[Music]
uh rings of acatan
i keep forgetting about this thing
because it leaves almost no impression
on me
like
about the only thing i remember from
that episode is the leaf
and that the doctor gives a speech about
memory that ironically i don't remember
a lot of the details of
so
like i like the idea of this again
because it's a wonderfully alien concept
of this sort of living star
pulling and and sustaining itself on
memories and possibilities and all these
things like it's a neat
idea i don't think the story it's in
does the idea justice at all though
um
i'm gonna go with not bad but not good
because again i don't think there's that
much wrong
with the concept but boy does it not get
done justice
all right what are we up to um ah the
nestine and the autons i suppose this is
just the autons technically um
so
confession time
i don't really like the autons
in any version i've seen them in i've
seen some classic i've seen them in
modern i don't they don't do a lot for
me
that said as a villain especially for
the very first episode of the revive
series in sort of getting the impression
across of what we're gonna be dealing
with what's a typical day in the
doctor's life like they're effective at
that
but again a bit like the dolls from
night terrors um i
just i just don't
find mannequins creepy so they don't do
much for me i know a lot of people bump
them up higher because like they're a
legacy villain but i just think they're
they're not bad but not good either
so
i have whoops
oh hang on a second
i just accidentally
i gotta pop that out again all right
here we go sorry i had accidentally um
uh x'ed out of the chat
and i want to be able to see what you
folks are saying
um again i'm just kind of peering at it
um reminder if you came in later like
i'll
super chat's probably the only way
you're really gonna actively get my um
attention because otherwise otherwise
we're going to be here forever if oh
geez i gotta pick up the pace i got to
pick up the pace on this holy cow
all right um
let's see here
let me
there's there's a lot of these i gotta
go faster than i'm going okay
um
the
oh my gosh
why
why is this out of my head
vashta narada yes
they're legendary i'll just go ahead and
plop them right up there because
the just the idea of the shadows in and
of themselves not every shadow but any
shadow the way that they act as a hive
of mind i can be iffy on hive minds i
think they work really well the fact
that these bodies still walk and they
repeat the line it's creepy it's awesome
the the idea of these things just in the
shadows is already scary the way they um
they are able to embody them and
oftentimes taking a more abstract
villain and giving it a more traditional
form will annoy me um but like here i
think it actually works really well i
think they're fantastic
um
mr sweet
and actually i don't even think he's the
villain i think she's the villain i
forget her name now um
but
uh she is actually
it was interesting going back and
re-watching crimson or because she's way
more effective as a villain than i
remembered her being especially when it
comes to conversations with her daughter
and you realize how much of
the whole thing is actually about um
familial abuse and how horribly she's
treated her daughter and she does a
really good job of embodying um
a really a very specific kind of deeply
toxic parental figure
i think she's pretty good
all right so what
what the hell is that what is this
what even
i don't know what that is
all right we're gonna come back to that
because
if anyone can figure out what the hell
this is even supposed to be i feel like
they misaligned the image i don't know
what that is somebody else figure it out
um
so we'll move to eyepatch lady whose
name i now forget
who was
fine she worked well enough as a
figurehead uh for series six as a
recurring villain but she never really
felt as though like she was at her most
effective
in um
[Music]
uh goodman goes to war and the way she
kind of outsmarted the doctor but other
than that one appearance she was just
kind of generically mysterious
um
yeah she was fine
um
[Music]
all right
from flatland oh i think you're right oh
i think you're right i think this is the
boneless
okay
um
ooh
[Music]
so
i like flatline quite a bit it's a
pretty good episode it does a lot of
good stuff for moving clara's story
forward working on that dynamic between
her and the doctor i actually like danny
pink and so you know how that's
impacting that relationship works really
well the boneless themselves are
a really interesting villain
but they were more effective before they
actually pulled out of the walls and
like started lurching at them like
zombies when it was just this flatness
that was trying to also make you
two-dimensional it was way more
interesting to what they actually became
later which was these two-dimensional
things moving about and like shooting
freaking lightning from their fingers
which unfortunately brought them down a
bit uh
that said they're still pretty good the
bits before they sort of solidify are
still good enough
um oh
okay the uh
the carrionites from
um
the shakespeare code
then
the only reason they work at all is
thematically because of the ties to you
know which
which is in shakespeare most
particularly in macbeth so
they're
you know they're fine
i think the thing is they they are in
the best story that they were ever going
to work in but they're all they also are
not great they're not bad but they're
not good
they're me their theme music is quite
good um
cassandra
oh
yes this is this
bigoted piece of flat bread yep um so
she is quite good i think her second
appearance doesn't work nearly as well
and in hindsight i'm not sure how much i
like about
um
sort of giving her a little bit of a
redemption
um
but oh don't don't sin don't worry about
the fact that i actually said macbeth
i'm not in a theater
if i if i was in a theater space i
wouldn't say it but i'm not
um but cassandra
cassandra is effective especially in her
first appearance her second one not as
much but not enough to drag her below
pretty good
oof sorry got a hiccup there on myself
um oh
charlie
dang it you know what
curblam came in with such a good idea
it's got a great vibe it has great
energy i want to like kerblam and i used
to like kerblam a lot more than i do but
a lot of what's wrong with it circles
around charlie how much of a strong man
he is
and framing him as the villain in the
way they do and the way the episode
fails to recognize what the actual
problem is i went off on a whole rant
when i did the take two review
charlie's pretty bad
he's pretty bad
no actually he's awful
charlie's awful not because the
performance is terrible but because
his execution and how he functions as a
villain
is actually
deeply detrimental to what was good
about
that episode prior because i think there
is a lot of good in kerblam but it falls
apart so hard and almost all of it
centers around him he drags it down he's
awful
uh the clockwork droids i already kind
of mentioned how i like inherently the
idea of machines that are just going
about what they were programmed to do
it's just once dropped into
circumstances the people who designed
them didn't imagine then that
programming suddenly becomes a problem
um they've got a really cool look both
with or without the masks
honestly i kind of say they're legendary
i'm and i'm kind of
putting them over the top on the basis
of
i just smile whenever i see somebody
cosplaying one of these things and i'm
like uh yeah
yeah that's good stuff
okay
um up the sun taurens so
the santarans are tough because they
really are a mixed bag centaurons can be
great or they can be
and that's true in classic and in modern
but when they're good they're great i
think they're quite good in the
two-parter they get with tenant i
actually
really like war of the santarans it's
the only episode i like from flux but i
like it a lot but in between there was
the whole stretch where they were
basically treated as a joke and it's
kind of because of strax not strike's
fault strikes is a good character but
they decided oh we're gonna have any
santorum we see for a while behave like
that and it's like oh
okay i unfortunately because of how
uneven they are taking the totality of
their use in the modern era together
i'm debating between pretty good and
not bad but not good that's that's where
the debate is right now
um
i'm still gonna go pretty good
but it's not by much they're kind of
hanging on by a thread
cyberman
so this is another one that like when
it's good it's great because when it's
great you get
um world enough in time and holy crap
but i don't like that
they
they went for a while with the alternate
universe cybermen nightmare and silver
wasn't good
that
the thing is the more i think about it i
think
they've only had a couple of sporadic
good uses
uh as villains in
modern doctor who
um i like like i like the one
um that's just trying to get a hold of
anybody it can in the pandorica opens i
actually think they're interestingly
used in um
oh cripes uh whatever the one is that
where craig comes back where they're
underneath the mall
um they're they're decently good they're
amazing in world enough in time but the
other stuff isn't great so again i'm
debating between
not bad but not good or pretty i go i'll
go pretty good because again when
they're good
they're great but um what is
is that
is that the eaters of light
i think it is
i think that's what that is chat
confirmed that closing time thank you um
chat confirmed that for me
uh and i'll come back to it ah the hand
robots uh the hand robots are pretty bad
uh they are the weakest uh aspect of an
episode that i otherwise really like i
think
that the girl who waited is a fantastic
episode but
the the hand robots like and i get why
they're so easy to take down because
like they're not designed to actually be
secured or whatever but like one of them
goes down because rory just
breaks a can a canva a painting canvas
over its head and it goes down like
really really there yeah there's really
not much to them
um
so
uh yeah so it is eaters of light
um
they're pretty bad they're not awful but
like it's they're fairly generic as
interesting an idea conceptually as like
something that devours light is there's
just almost nothing done with them and
they're just generic horde monster
there's just not much there
oh the dalek from
dalek
uh yo
legendary absolute legend of that one
especially if i'm putting the supreme
dolly cup here dude yeah that dalek
specifically oh so good
so so good and does such a good job of
using just one dialect to show this is
why they are terrifying so then later
when they show up in numbers you're like
oh crap
uh it's good it's good good good so good
uh oh and dalek
which one is this this is dalek
sec
so i don't
know
if they're gonna okay yeah they've got
the uh the sort of merged version later
on so this is just when he is a dalek
and he's leading the cult of scaro i'm
gonna say he's pretty good
um i think they did a decent job of
having the call discaro be more
imaginative and behave in ways the
doctor couldn't predict i kind of wish
they'd done more with that before
getting rid of them but no this is
pretty solid
that just looks like uh generic somewhat
aged dalek from uh
uh which is familiar i don't think
that's supposed to be anything specific
it's a dalek though it's still pretty
good actually you know what it's just
it's a filler dalek so it's just there
to take up space it's not bad but it's
not good
like other daleks can be good that one
just yeah
whatever
um
is that
who is that
what is she from because i for a second
i was mistaking her for
uh miss foster over here i'm not
somebody remind me who she is
um oh this is the dalek from
revolution
of the daleks uh the one where like
they're being used as cops
that was an interesting idea that was
not properly fleshed out that could have
been a lot better than it is
um so i'm gonna go with not bad not good
like lower end of daleks decent idea but
um
so let's oh time heist oh she's the one
from time i i completely forgot about
her i 100 forgot about her
i don't remember her being bad though
so we'll go not bad but not good oh i'm
realizing now that i'm actually going to
have to adjust this window a little bit
because i'm pretty soon i'm not
going to be able to see
okay there we go so if i do that how's
that look
there we go because i if i if i kept it
at the size that it was i was i was not
going to be able to see anything
pretty soon okay all right all right all
right so coming back
and let's see
so oh
the
the dregs
from orvin 55
they're pretty bad they're not awful
it's only because the design is actually
pretty decent well until they put put it
out in daylight when it's in the
darkness is pretty good but like
conceptually they're
uninteresting unoriginal
actually you know what take it back i'm
gonna put them at awful because
because the fact that they show them in
broad daylight shows that they didn't
even understand the limited capacity in
which these things worked
visually so yeah
now this is interesting because i'm not
sure i would have
considered
uh a shielder to be the villain of face
the raven
she's
kind of the problem
in a lot of ways but i don't know it
feels almost odd to consider her the
villain but if that's how they're doing
it assessing her as a villain
i guess she falls under the category of
um sort of an uncaring villain oh um
bernard city update channel thank you
very much for the super chat are you my
mummy friends still mock me with this oh
we'll get there it's coming up um but as
sort of an unfeeling villain someone who
has their own agenda and isn't trying to
do bad things but like doesn't really
care if people get hurt she works pretty
effectively for that but again
i have a hard time even thinking of her
as the villain so i'm gonna go with
not bad but not good like effective
enough and i do like face the raven
quite a bit um
and i like the character but if i'm
assessing her as a villain it's gonna be
middling if i'm assessing her as a
character she'd actually be higher
um
i think
that is that the editor he's really
small chat confirm to me that that's the
editor i'll come back to him sasha
dewan's master
who
i feel like i'm only going to have a
solid final answer
um with with him after the the centenary
special
but
um right now
i
i feel like his manic energy works quite
well he is quite intimidating he gets
introduced really well
but i also kind of feel like
he later on got used largely as a
vehicle for exposition of really bad
ideas i.e the timeless child
so he's gonna go i'm pretty good
he is good but uh use on him is
yeah
um
so let's see uh so
i think we did conf oh no no they're
saying it's mr finch ah so it's not the
editor it's mr finch oh
oh
mr finch is legendary he's legendary
because it's anthony stewart head and
there are not a lot of villains there
are not well there's not a lot of actors
who you can have go face to face with
the doctor
um and
you know be someone who isn't recurring
has no history but can still project the
sense of oh
this guy's a threat to the doctor and
come across as legitimately intimidating
he can pull it off i have i've been
saying for
years
years
that i want him to come back i don't
care about the rest of the correlatings
but i want him back he was so good
so good
ha
oh
are you my mummy oh god immediately
legendary tear that thing
freaked me out it freaks me out not just
because of the mask and the all you my
mummy just the mo it's one of those
things where the more i found out about
it the scarier i actually found it
because it has this whole thing of it's
so powerful but it's also got the
fractured mind of a child and it doesn't
even understand the damage it's doing
and i find that horrifying i gotta go
faster family of blood
legendary
uh mother of mine father of mine sister
of mine oh it's they're all so good
they're all so good they're so unnerving
just even just the the sniffing like ah
they're great and and and to have like
it would have worked with just the one
but having the four of them oh yeah
they're fantastic
the jejune
the jejune are not good but they're
they're not bad but they're not good um
like the whole thing with them is
they've just kind of been stand-ins for
like we need some grunts that aren't
that aren't 100 evil they're a little
bit meh
um they just get slotted in for that and
they work fairly effectively they work
in fugitive of jejune they work in smith
and jones but like
as uh as a character in and of
themselves like i certainly wasn't
clamoring to have them back
um miss foster
um
like the whole thing with the adipose
you know what okay if i'm not thinking
of the adipose as a villain just the way
she operates
she works again a little bit kind of in
the way a shoulder does although more
definitively villainous in terms of
being just an uncaring villain like she
has what she's doing she doesn't really
care what the damage is as long as she
gets done what she wants she's actually
pretty good for that
um i actually think partners in crime is
kind of an overrated episode but she's
fine prisoner zero
is effective in the episode that he's in
which is 11th hour but
um
is probably one of the weaker elements
he's a filler villain because that
episode is doing so much it's
introducing a new doctor new companions
the way in which the two of them met
which is unusual like
he's the
prisoner zero just is the thing that
needs to be there because there needs to
be a monster and he works but he's not
fantastic so we'll drop him there
um oh the minotaur i like the minotaur a
lot uh i i like the look of it i like
conceptually how it works i love the
idea that it
feeds off of faith and i love the way
that that works and
the fact that it's effectively in a
prison and it doesn't even want to be
there or kind of rather die but if
you're gonna put food in front of it
it's gonna eat most people can't
willfully starve themselves and he can't
he's yep
yep he's good oh the doctor interesting
that they have the doctor here and not
the uh not the cyborg i guess the doctor
is a bit more of the not not the doctor
but this doctor i forget his name from a
town called mercy he's
pretty bad actually if you were
assessing him as a villain as a
character he's fine
as a villain all his villainy is
historical uh none of it is stuff he's
doing right now really at least that i
can remember i don't remem i can never
remember a town called mercy that well
yeah
missy
straight to legendary missy
is one of the best iterations of the
master and she frequently battles it out
with delgado in my head for being the
best iteration of the master i love
missy
so much
so much she is
mwah
she's excellent
the oh the berninators i don't know what
they're actually called but the
burninators from 42 deeply unnecessary
that was an episode and that was a story
where the situation
was the threat and that was enough it it
did not need a monster that having been
said the whole burn with me thing is a
bit unnerving and it's relatively
effective but the fact that they don't
need to be there at all but still are
i'm gonna go with pretty bad
uh
the oh the um the head the head crabs
again i forget what they actually are
but the head crabs from last christmas
um
they look creepy when they do the open
up that's actually quite unnerving
the way they work i actually like quite
they're pretty good they're pretty good
those things i actually wouldn't even
mind those things coming back which to
me is usually a sign of being pretty
good
who the is that
is that mr razor
chat confirmed for me on that
ah the emoji bots
i actually like the emoji bots i think
they're pretty good for a similar reason
that i brought up with the
uh clockwork droids and the rest it you
know they're they're machines they don't
think like people and when they
encounter something that they
don't have the programming to deal with
they don't know how to react and they
respond in a way that is not what we
would want but we didn't account for it
when programming them i actually think
they're pretty effective i like them
and uh
and the idea of
[Music]
just the the use of emojis works pretty
well like uh stu bagful is an excellent
episode on that um
oh kazrin
oh
okay so that's um
[Music]
christmas carol
he's fine you know
it's
it's you know an alternate version of
scrooge he's fine he works for it he
couldn't even recognize him so
ah the uh the invisible monster from
uh vincent and the doctor
in terms of uh effective use in the
story really good
really good
um and like metaphorical and how it
works and what it is and how it impacts
things and the way the episode frames
and deals with depression and the impact
not only the people who are depressed
but the people around them trying to
help but they can't see the thing that
is causing pain it works really well
it wouldn't work especially well taken
out of that context and it's a little
bit
like it's kind of like like a weird
chicken face and all this but
it's really good for the story it's in
and so for that i'm going to go with
pretty good
the gelf
the gels are
they're fine
they're not bad they're not good they
are
they're just kind of generic oh we
tricked you into uh
into helping us but we're actually bad
but you know they're just these wispy
things it
it's not uninteresting but like i keep
forgetting they're a thing
which is usually uh not a great sign how
we doing oh boy okay pick up the pace
pick it up the future kind
uh the future kind of pretty bad
actually for the exact same reason that
that the berninators are bad which is
that
uh the story doesn't need them
like the threat is the universe is
ending time is collapsing entropy has
won
adding in like
jagged teeth humans is
just not necessary they don't need to be
there they're fine
but they're them being not needed drops
them down there
so
this douche okay so first of all i do
have to set aside
um for the purpose of this my feelings
about chris noth uh in specific which
aren't great right now but
um
how he how effective was he as a villain
not too bad
actually having re-watched um at least
his first appearance
while i think the the
political metaphorical
presidential trumpian stuff was
unnecessary in terms of again that that
very unfeeling bill uncaring indifferent
villain who's just gonna do what he
wants and he doesn't care he just wants
things to go his way regardless of the
fallout
he's pretty effective
for that
i
i don't want to do this because
i
i want to put him lower because i hate
arachnids in the uk i
hate
that
i want to put him in pretty bad or even
awful but i can't bring myself to it
because for what he is
he's decently effective
oh this was the woman who put the bug on
um
on donna's back for left turn
uh
or turn left i always do it backwards i
always say left turn it but it's turn
left i think
it's one that i can't remember um
but she like does almost nothing she's
just there she's just the thing that
plants it
and
just
she works for that but like there isn't
a lot of personality to her
the uh
the gangers
i like the gangers because there is a it
does a good job of like how messy and
complicated their situation is and sort
of justifying their anger for how they
have been treated thinking that it's not
um
thinking that they aren't conscious but
treating them the way that they do
i actually think they're pretty good
i think that two-parter in general is
underrated who the hell is that
and who the hell is that
i don't know who either of these two
are i
duh
chat help me out i'm moving on to the
emperor dalek who does have that big
booming voice that i love so much but
honestly he didn't
do much and i suppose you could argue
neither did the supreme dalek but the
difference is i felt like for how built
up the emperor dalek is i feel like he
should
have done more
yeah
just gonna go in pretty good
this is from
flux
i don't remember oh and he okay so this
guy
is the
uh
the prime minister
from um
beast below
i hadn't thought of him as a villain i
would have thought the of the smilers
um but if we take it as him being in
control of them
he's
actually pretty good in terms of
believing that what he's doing is
necessary even while recognizing that
it's pretty terrible
yeah actually i had never even thought
to assess him as a villain
but uh yeah
gat from fugitive legit god i don't
remember her at all
like at all
which means she goes in the middle you
might think that would put her at pretty
bad but like you'd have to do something
to stick in my head as being bad if i
can't remember you at all that's just
the definition of mid
um
the ood so assessing the ood as villains
is interesting because really the only
time that they're villains is when
they're under the command of the beast
in uh
in
the impossible planet in the satan pit
this this stream's gonna go longer than
i planned i'm already accepting that um
i am that's that said i am gonna try and
move along so if we're dealing we we're
gonna have to deal specifically with the
possessed dude because the ud we see in
planet uh of view they are not the
villains they are the heroes so
they basically just work as a horde
and they could have been replaced with
almost anything which so assessing the
possessed ood they are suitably creepy
but you also could have replaced them
with almost anything and it would have
been effectively the same so that's got
to go in the middle
oh dear god
um
the dalek sec hybrid
what a fascinating idea that was
super uh unpleasant to look at not
interesting to listen to
and didn't really go anywhere
it was pretty bad
like i love the concept behind how he
came to be but like there just isn't
much there
the ice warriors they've been
interesting in the revival
because they've only popped up the two
times so far cold war and empress of
mars and i think they've been handled
relatively decently
but nothing is really
like if they'd been anything else they
would have been just kind of like oh
yeah right those things the the fact
that they have a legacy adds a little
bit but not a lot they're
they're not bad but they're not good
they have they haven't been given a
great story yet
uh who is that sheriff of nottingham
uh confirmed that for me chat you guys
are really helpful i app i appreciate
that
um oh the angels from
um uh voyage of the damned yeah they're
pretty bad actually i don't think the
look is that impressive uh the number of
times you hear them go information uh
kill
kill
kill i hate machines that announce what
they're doing as they do it i hate that
as a trope
so yeah they're pretty bad
um
so anyway
the sheriff yes it is yes it's the
sheriff okay uh the sheriff
he was
good
he was fine
um i like i actually like robots uh of
sherwood a lot
but it's largely for the banter and the
vibe and the rollicking adventure and
it's a lot of it's robin
uh the sheriff was
fine like he might have gone higher
except i can't think of sheriff of
nottingham without thinking of
of alan rickman
um
from robin hood and the prince of
thieves i wish i could remember any of
the lines from that because i'd quote
them but he's really he's yeah
it's it's hard to measure up
oh god the wire
oh
so this is even setting aside the
reasons that i do and always will deeply
loathe
loathe the idiot's lantern even setting
all those aside which i've done multiple
videos on i'm not going to go on it here
the wire starts out so interesting with
that calm voice like are you sitting
comfortably then we'll begin but just
devolves into this thing that just goes
feed me hungry i'm like shut
up
i hate by the time it's done i hate her
so much
ah
it could have been really good they had
a really good actress for what they were
going for the vibe and then they just
oh
it's so bad
huh
the jagrafess
the geographers of the
holy something
uh
elaine rodenfo something i don't know i
can't remember uh the geographers is uh
it's not bad it's not good
it's it's a generic
uh ceiling monster it works
but like
the editor is the way more effective
villain of that and i'll be curious to
see if he pops up on here because they
don't seem to be doing um too much in
the way of multiple villains from the
same story they seem to be picking one
so if that's what they're picking for
the villain for um where'd he go oh
there is if that's what they're like
picking for the villain from
uh
the long game then they went with the
weaker one because the editor is
actually quite good he's
whatever the mighty geographers of the
holy hatred jason maxo rhoden vote thank
you thank you as likes tech um well done
so okay oh the santa robot the santa
robots are
pretty i'm tempted to go awful
we're gonna go with pretty bad just
because
they
they fit the aesthetic they fit the
holiday aesthetic fine
but like whatever
um
oh i forget her name but from the bells
of saint john
i actually rather like her she feels
very in command and then what happens at
the end is
deeply tragic like it unsettles me
that when she gets released from the
great intelligences um
sort of hold over her that like she's
been in his control for so long she
thinks she's still a child like the
tragedy brings it up to pretty good for
me that that gives it an extra boost uh
what the hell is that
i don't know what that is chat help me
out there we'll move on to okay so we're
going with human villain from demons of
the punjab uh
not bad but not good you know is he is
effective for what he's used for that
was a story that for what's doing it
needed to have a human villain and he
does it
decently enough
yeah
gridlock oh it's the oh
it's the macra
um
also pretty bad actually
that's another case of the story didn't
need the monster you know gridlock would
have worked just as well if not better
um without them oh geez i gotta hold on
i gotta shrink down the
there we go and i shrink that down again
uh just because i i need to be able to
see the dang thing okay
all righty moving on oh the dream master
love him
i love the dream the dream lord so much
i he that's another one who i want to
come back i don't care what the
logistics are i don't care how you do it
oh toby jones was so good and he was so
skeevy and he was such a perfect
counterbalance specifically to the smith
doctor but i want to see how he shapes
up being a counterbalance to any of the
later doctors oh he was so good
so good and irritating he's skeevy and
oh
i guess we are doing multiple things
from um from this because these are the
robots from roger wood and we've got the
sheriff um
they're pretty bad like they're just
generic they could have been anything
um
oh
the okay so
this dude and the whole
sand people i guess i'll call them from
sleep no more
uh i'm trying see i'm debating right now
between
uh not bad not good and pretty bad
because like conceptually i just think
they're so stupid but there is there was
a little bit of effective imagery
him falling apart at the end
uh
decent as a final note of a horror thing
goes but it's also for the horror genre
it's very generic yeah pretty bad
pretty bad
um we'll go with that uh
the oh the rave the raven itself
huh
huh interesting
um not bad not good because it's not a
character it's just a function and it's
not even like some of the some of the
monsters that we don't get to know that
well but like it
the the raven is a plot function and as
a plot function it's great but it's like
i can't really assess it as a
as a villain
oh these things the things that split
their i always forget these things exist
and then i remember and
i know i've said with some of the other
things when i forget it exists it goes
in mid except whenever i remember them
i'm like oh yeah and like he had a gun
in his head like why not just have it in
a holster so they're clearly idiots
they're pretty bad
okay so this is interesting
because i like
it takes you away and i like the solute
track and i like that it's a frog but
i've never really
um
considered it as a villain
it i mean it's lonely it's not trying to
hurt anybody but it is still the cause
of the problems
so
i'm gonna go with pretty good like i
love the solar track like i love it as a
conception but
i don't feel it's it's enough
um
fully in the vein of a villain to put it
any higher than pretty good but like
again as i've noted a couple times i
like really weird ideas
i like when really weird ideas seep into
sci-fi and that's a really weird idea i
love it too much
um
the weeping angels
they're pretty good
they're pretty good they have been uh
frustratingly overused i have to keep
making this smaller i forgot how many
things there are on this they they are
frustratingly overused um it's been
diminishing turns pretty much all the
way down but
their first appearance was amazing
uh their second appearance was pretty
good and added some interesting new
ideas and as much as logistically the
angels take manhattan falls apart really
badly they are well used in terms of
being an exit point for
um amy and rory
but i'm not putting them higher than
that because it has it it has been
diminishing returns for for a while now
they are a good concept though
there's the cyborg uh he's
he's fine
he's mid
he's fine
um
i know
i know that face but why am i drawing a
blank
why am i drawing a blank
i don't know i'm drawing a blank on that
too chat help me out on these two
um oh the the what oh they're they're
awful
i know i've put most of the cases of
there didn't need to be a monster um in
pretty bad but not awful but they these
things morax that's what they are they
are legitimately awful because they they
wreck the episode and they require so
much exposition to work
um and
yeah they they completely kill what's
good about oh sky silvestri midnight oh
yeah top
absolute legend the midnight entity is
ah
oh
man
oh midnight's real real good
um
these are what oh the kill the moon
spiders
they're pretty bad that's that's uh
that's another unnecessary
monster like the situation of the moon's
gonna break apart is already enough of a
problem
like you don't need the monsters
so
uh the werewolf you know what the cgi
does not hold up at all but it's not bad
but it's not good
it's it it's decent
it's fine
it's fine
oh okay so oh
they are breaking up oh they're breaking
up
the
cybermen into different appearances oh
first of all i need to reassess this one
down to not bad not bad but not good
because that's the cybus men
specifically um
because these ones are the
ones from nightmare and silver
and they're also not bad but not good uh
i appreciate the idea of like a
more fully upgraded like they have been
improving and like they're more
dangerous and if there's even one on a
planet you have to destroy the whole
planet but like
it's just not a good episode they're not
well used okay
okay here's controversy time the new
paradigm daleks
they're pretty good
they weren't
utilized almost at all after their first
appearance but i love the idea of them i
don't have a problem with the with the
skittles color theme
i
thought their introduction was really
neat i wanted to see more of them i
really really did
it's a shame we didn't get to i like
them
uh oh this dude from um
why can't i think of episode
names today the doctor's daughter he's
fine
it's not bad he's not good he works for
the purposes oh house
house is great house is legendary
oh yeah
oh i love house again with that just
just with the voice the sense of
strength and
power and like oh man he's gonna tear
apart everything yeah i know he's good
he's real good i like house a lot and
again wonderfully bizarre concept it's
like a trash ball planet but it's also
conscious
it's oh it's weird it's creepy the voice
is fantastic michael sheen i oh yeah
yeah yeah it's real good
uh these are oh these are the things
from um
uh
the girl who the girl who lived the girl
who died because it's the girl who died
the woman who lived the girl who died
they're
fine like they did they would go down to
pretty bad if i felt the story didn't
need them it kind of does but they're
fine
um
oh uh
donaghada you are amazing thank you so
much for the for the super chat for the
sticker much appreciated i like that
thank you very much
um okay john sims master
is not bad but not good so like here's a
big distinction for me there's something
about the manic energy that sasha
dewan's master has that works in a way
that sims doesn't and i'm gonna have to
quantify that better when i eventually
do a master re-ranking but
sim worked better for me as time went on
but
in his initial
series three i didn't like him at all
and he was fine in the end of the end of
time two-parter i liked him best in the
doctor falls but he just he hasn't been
great for me
uh
so this
that just looks like generic
dalek i don't think that's a specific
one
which would put it at pretty good
because dollars generally are pretty
good the sycorax
the cigarettes are pretty good actually
they're kind of silly but i kind of like
the way that they operate in that it's
it's all show and bluster and like blood
control which makes which makes people
afraid and ready to surrender because
they think you know they can make people
walk off a route but they can't it's
just a trick so i i like that they are
intimidating but like a lot of it is
just bluster
yeah i like them they're effective
um
okay so this is
this is the cyberman from
the next doctor
i believe
he's fine they're fine
they're fine
oh the the mutated pig slaves
pretty bad unnecessary ooh
okay i'm slightly cheating i'm slightly
cheating putting
um
derek jacoby's warmaster up in legendary
because i know i said i was going to
restrict this to how they worked within
new who
but
but
i have listened to some of his stuff on
big finish and i can't pretend it
doesn't exist he's so good we did not
get nearly enough of him on screen but
he's so good he's so goddamn good
oh that was cyber controller from age
from age of steel okay that's still not
bad not good he stays the same place
regardless uh ooh mommy on the orient
express
is pretty
mmm
is it pretty good or is he legendary is
he pretty good or is he legend he
i'm looking at who he's clustered with
he is up here i like the mummy a lot i
love
i love just how old school horror movie
he looks and the feel and the slow
movement and the countdown clock and
just the sense of the way he's defeated
i like that mummy a lot i love that
episode anyways but i like that mummy a
lot that's a legendary mummy
um oh it's lion-o
from uh the woman who lived
he's actually pretty bad
um it could have been not
bad but not good that story does kind of
need a villain but like it's just so
freaking
generic
like whatever
um
oh uh what's his face from husbands of
river song the one who actually whose
body that actually is and if i count the
body as a villain too is actually
it's actually pretty good as far as
shouty villains go
he's he's appropriately hateable
he's not shouting 100 of the time he
does calm down a few times which gives
him some layers he's pretty good
hydraflex thank you it's pretty good um
oh
okay so heather
i believe her name is but this is the um
this is the sentient oil from the pilot
which is pretty good again it's such a
weird concept and i honestly honestly
think that they did dripping water um
as a scary effect more effectively here
than in waters of mars
i don't think anyone else believes that
but that's what i think
um oh evil capitalist from thin ice oh
yeah he's pretty good he is pretty good
as a villain he's deeply hateable and
that that story needed a human villain
specifically he's real good for that
he's just
he's just bad
as a human being but in a way that human
beings are
not unreasonably just very much in that
way oxygen okay so what they've gotten
there is they've got a body in the suit
so i'm going to asses here with oxygen
i'm going to assess it as
the system
and the ai that is running things or
honestly even the corporation and
putting all that into play
that's legendary that is capitalism is
the villain which is a little bit what's
going on with the guy from thin ice but
oxygen did it bigger oxygen did it
better oxygen did it creepier and oxygen
did it in a way that like yeah yeah if
we ever get to a point where it is
possible to monetize air yeah this is
actually what would happen and anyone
who says that wouldn't happen like why
do we pay for water
we all need water
you need water to live
they're already making us pay for a
vital
life
sustaining resource
why would they stop there if they could
do it with anything else
um ooh
world enough in time the monda cybermen
yep oh
wow they were so creepy they were so
creepy
oh it brought back that body horror so
well for the cybermen oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah good stuff
oh this is the uh the dalek from
resolution
excuse me so this is the reconnaissance
dalek
which is pretty good
having re-watched that one relatively
recently
i like i like the idea of it i like the
way it pilots a human being i like the
way that it cobbles together its own
casing
um i just i i think it's actually pretty
effective i would be down for
another reconnaissance dalek showing up
again at some point
oh this is the dude from um spyfall
he's fine he's mid
he's effective enough
more daleks i'm not sure what from
huh uh
if anyone can tell me what story those
daleks are from let me know
uh the ghosts in
the uh
uh under the lake and before the flood
they're pretty effectively creepy
they're pretty good
by the end it's kind of debatable how
much of the villains well they are yeah
i know they you can count them as the
villains we'll see if the fisher king
shows up um but yeah they're effectively
creepy
um the dalek prime minister from asylum
of the daleks oh
okay
he's pretty good
i know some people like a lot of people
deeply hate asylum i'm sorry i think
it's real good
um
the ting
the pating is awful
the patang is yet another case where it
the
circumstances didn't need a monster you
just needed to have the ship breaking
down that was ultimately the threat
having it be this tiny stitch looking
thing it's no
and no the pating doesn't work at all
pira uh the pyrovillians
they're fine
they work well enough uh all things
considered
okay i should i shouldn't have to shrink
the uh
the uh the window anymore from there i
think we've got it now
um actually hang on let me let me
shift that over a little bit
um so you can see more of what's coming
up uh so we're so this is the home
stretch this is the home stretch at this
point
um but yeah the pyrovisions they're fine
fires of pompe is actually quite good
but it's really good as a character
piece um for the doctor and donna
especially um and it's got a strong
supporting cast but the pyrovillians
they're fine
oh so okay so we've got all right we've
got the arachnus queen and then whatever
the equivalent was from
nikola tesla's night of terror the
ragnaros queen is pretty bad
um
the design is real cool and i love that
it's practical
but
you can tell like yeah chris couldn't
speak around the mouthpiece and they
didn't have her dump it over
so like she sounds terrible and she
spends like half her time going my
children
which was which was a shame because it's
a really good visual design i think the
um
the variation that we got in nicola
tessa was better and so go that goes up
to
not bad but not good
all right
here's where we get to be potentially
controversial again the reapers
the reapers are awful
because this is another case of
this is a story that needs no villain
needs no monster
time is falling apart you do not need to
embody that in a monster that is never
going to show up again which makes no
sense logistically given the
circumstances you said under which they
come about we should have seen them more
times i'm glad we haven't because i
think they're stupid um and hopefully
all future writers for doctor who do as
well but
you don't need them
everything good about that episode and i
do think father's day is overrated
anyways but everything good about that
episode is about the character
interactions it's about the drama it's
about the sense of loss of trying to
grab onto something that you
have never had and you can just like
imagine if there wasn't a monster on the
church door instead
they look down the street and it's
nothing
and then and that is what's encroaching
you open the church door and like
there's just a void and it's just
everything is compressing down you don't
need them as a monster they drag it down
they're not interesting in their design
i hate them i hate them
um
oh duh this is more cybus men yeah
they're they're fine
they're fine that's yeah that's all
that's all i've got to say about them
um
what is this
i'm not sure what that is
uh
help me out chat i'm not sure what that
is these things i forget what they are i
forget what they're called
but they're actually pretty effective
design and pretty weird i think they're
pretty good uh they're from spyfall
okay
the silence the silence is
tough for me
because conceptually and this was a
bit of a oh it's the sexy vampire fish
okay we'll come back to that green man
group
okay so the silence conceptually i think
is actually scarier than the weeping
angels
and i think in their first appearance
they are
masterfully used
and unfortunately much like the weeping
angels we get diminishing returns every
time they show up
so i want if i could restrict it to
their first appearance if i could
restrict it
to
um
the to
uh the impossible astronaut and day of
the moon they'd be legendary but if i
have to take everything into account
they are pretty good and i wish i could
put i could put them higher than that so
sexy vampire fish they're they're
they're they're pretty bad they're
generic and they just yeah
um so the silurians from the two-parter
uh
hollow earth and cold blood
um
so
if i'm assessing this one specifically
whose name i now forget
um
she is
the standard for a silorian villain
which is the one who refuses to accept
the idea of peace
and
you know it has the standard problem a
lot of those have which is a fundamental
and reasonableness if you don't get to
know them really well they just come
across as pig-headed a little bit straw
manny which she does
it's effective it works but whatever oh
the uh the cat nurses
they're they're pretty bad i mean the
design isn't great their whole plan is
weird and convoluted oh geez this thing
from the caretaker it's awful remember
how i said earlier i hate when uh
robotic things like announce what
they're doing like how the angels were
the the not the weeping angels but the
angels from uh voyage of the damn were
going kill
kill this thing i'd forgotten this until
i rewatched it this thing announces it's
every single move
targeting searching firing like shut up
who designs a weapon to announce loudly
what it's doing it's oh it's so bad
the skovox blitzer thank you you folks
are really coming through for me
it's just so
dumb
it's so dumb oh the giant spiders
they're pretty bad
um
like there isn't like i've said with a
number of other things i don't find
there's a lot of things i don't find
inherently creepy i don't find
mannequins or clowns or
um you know that kind of stuff
inherently creepy i do find spiders a
little bit creepy though so that's
what's keeping them off awful they are
super generic uh as a thing
but
what out whatever
um
daleks again
not sure where those are from this one
is it's just a background
it was just a retro dalek from
which is familiar it's fine there was no
reason for it to be there this guy
this guy is almost good he's not though
so this is from um
oh crap what's what's it called uh
knock knock
and he's he's
the where things go with that get weird
in a way that doesn't work like i do
like weird but weird sometimes derails
it and he had a good vibe he had a good
performance but his character doesn't
quite work
uh the beast i love the beast
i love the beast i love the beast
whether it is that thing or whether it's
possessing somebody like i love this
thing i love this thing
and it's just so
[Music]
oh it's so massive and
just trying to wrap your head around
like how can you be real and even the
doctor having to go i accept that you
exist i don't have to accept what you
are but your physical existence i'll
give you that
oh
i like the beast a lot
um
what else we got here oh these things
though so these weird generic
things that are from um
[Music]
power of three they're they're basically
just zombies they're fine they function
uh
i'm jumping around because i'm trying to
tell what some of this stuff is the
zygons
those icons have been pretty good
actually when they've been brought back
um so yeah they can go there
i am trying to wrap it wrap it up i'm
trying to finish up in an hour and a
half
um
so let's see oh the slitheen
you know what i've softened on them a
little bit before i would have put them
under pretty bad
but
i'm gonna go with not bad but not good
for them the the visual design hurts
them a lot but they're not too bad
special weapons dalek is yeah i mean
it's there just to get a pop from fans
it's fine there's nothing wrong with
having it there i just don't care that
much is this is this anything other than
just a generic dalek this one over here
can people tell me
and also what the hell is this
i can't tell what that is either is that
praxis i can't remember what the villain
there is
uh
i don't know
um so these are sort of the metal eating
sting rate things
they're very generic they're just we
need a monster here's a monster
they're not bad they don't add anything
but they're not bad
uh
okay so that is praxius
um
this is magician's apprentice so this is
just again this is another filler dalek
all right so praxius all right
trying to decide what to do with praxis
is tricky
because
um i actually the the the way it
manifests on the skin it actually super
unnerves me
but i can barely remember anything other
than the look of it so i gotta think i
think i gotta put them in
not bad but not good because
as creepy as like the formation of it is
on people like it does unsettle me a lot
i can't remember anything else about
them than that
so
yeah
so this is from journey the center of
the tardis
this is pretty bad
this is pretty bad because oh geez i
have to i do have to keep
shrinking it down okay we're almost
there we're almost there
um
so
yeah the journey to the center of the
tardis was a great title and a good idea
but like finding out what these things
are is it's dumb
and they're they weren't that creepy in
the first place
um actually you know what i can't i
can't see when it's this small so i'm
just gonna have to scroll it down
um oh is that oh that's that's the
lazarus the lazarus monster is awful
the lazarus monster i can safely call
awful because it looks terrible
the cgi is terrible the concept of it
does not work at all like you're really
going to try and tell me that
um
this thing is somewhere coated in the
human dna no you reach too far it's it's
dumb and that episode's not good anyway
oh um pius 83 thank you very much for
the super chat appreciate the love for
them on dassy and cybermen uh without
world enough in time new who makes it
hard to be a cyberman fan that's fair
they are really good in that though
aren't they
um
here's the thing about simshaw
as a concept unto himself
he's not awful
he's not recurring villain worthy
but the teeth are kind of uh unsettling
the voice works
um i think the idea that he is basically
cheating at what he's doing
tracks
the stories that he's in especially the
last one are not good at all and the way
the narrative bends over backwards
to try and make him a threat doesn't
work at all but that's a problem with
the story not the i think actually as a
villain
he is
he's not bad he's not bad he's not good
but he's not bad
um the
taclophane kind of generic until you get
to the revelation of what they are
but that revelation is pretty damn
unnerving so they get to plop right up
there
uh
so this is the sort of
um
cyber leader
from i believe
uh
the next doctor
he's just you know a cybermen i i mean i
like that they brought back the
sort of open casing where you could see
the brain that was a nice call back
visually but like not a lot gets done
with him and what the hell is that oh
okay so we get to end on
the um oh
cnc 97 thank you very much for the
sticker i appreciate that we get to end
on the
uh the thing that was hunting the doctor
in
heaven
sent which is one of my favorite
episodes
and that thing's real unsettling
the sense we get from it the flies that
accompany it
i love that we never get a proper look
at it
because it is
a little bit more of a narrative
function than than
something that actually thinks for
itself
i can't put in legendary it is pretty
good like the episode's legendary it is
pretty good how do we fill out okay so
we've got the most in
actually we've got okay no we've got the
most in the mid-range where it's like oh
that works that's fine that's not awful
um and then we've got actually the next
most in pretty good
which is nice to see um that pretty good
is filled out quite decently and i think
some of this has to do with like me
thinking of these as villains almost
sometimes separate from the stories
they're in sometimes they get stories
that aren't worthy of them but sometimes
like that's actually that's a pretty
good villain could have been a great one
in a better story
um and then in terms of bulky then it's
pretty bad
which yeah
that and that pretty bad is mostly
filled out
with a lot of things that are either
ultra generic
or
didn't need to be there in the first
place
um that's where a lot of those are
uh and then it's legendary
which this is the uh this is the upper
echelon
i think these are the legendary villains
uh supreme dalek house i forget what
they're called but the two gods from can
you hear me
the clockwork androids midnight entity
missy the dalek from dalek the dream
lord
vashta narada mr finch the empty child
the family of blood
the war master the mummy the i'm just
gonna call it the system from oxygen the
mondassian cyberman and the beast like
that's a legendary lineup in my mind
and that
means that the least occupied
is actually the awful category
which is also nice to see like the ones
that are down there oh boy
oh boy
like and that's the thing like some some
some of these stories i'm like i don't
like these stories at all but the
villain isn't the problem these are all
down here because they're cases of the
villain and or monster is a big part of
the problem maybe it's even the only
thing that's deeply wrong with it like
say with father's day but like they're
they bring nothing positive they don't
even work as fill-in
yeah but it's nice to see that that
ended up being the
least occupied section
so
yeah
that's actually gonna wrap us up
um
with all of this
i'm thank you all for
joining me uh it's funny i actually
i actually had no clue how many people
were in the chat because the way i had
to have it set up my sort of concurrent
viewers section i wasn't in which i'm
now seeing the decent turnout for this
thank you very much hope folks had fun
um
i i'm
live shows like this are not i'm not
planning to make these a regular feature
of saturdays i needed to do it this week
because i really needed something that
didn't require prep time
because i needed the time to finish up
some other things um some of which is
for this channel i've also got a video
going up on the vera wild channel on
wednesday that i've been working on
forever so like to try and get some of
that stuff done i needed the breathing
room that's why we did this but i think
it was fun i had fun and i hope you did
too
so
uh thank you very much for joining me
and
i want you to remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned and now for
something that people who don't come to
the normal live streams will not
understand
my cavity